how we go red
my name is beer ah and welcome to Oh on
a Tuesday Monday Tuesday was on a
Thursday anyway we're gonna open some
packages can we get a shot on the
packages please
all right that's a lot of stuff to get
up but let's know what this one is from
Nick
brofist pants I'm not gonna broke with
you you [ __ ]
sorry sorry it's just the thing we do we
absolutely love your videos each and
every one of them they're so funny and
you never fail to make us laugh even
when we're sad thanks for that that is
so sweet
thank you all and a lot of brofist well
this one is clearly the best one I like
your choice of the paper size next
package so he sent me oh I love these
you sent me a lot of them thank you yeah
[ __ ] yeah for being a genius [ __ ] yeah
I don't know if anyone remembers I don't
know like a month ago I kept saying
where's my genius award well here it is
it's legit evidence that I'm a [ __ ]
genius it's a special [ __ ] out of it on
my brows I was like that ki-sun and
happy lives last but not least our thing
our God and creator our Lord and Savior
it's a sauna
thanks man bro this IX package oh [ __ ]
One Direction quiz it's actually legit
game I'll have to try it sometime
oh I scare you now is that our
appearance how can you answer
person what is st. last make it's my
like because I like vain look at this by
the way my genius award we're gonna get
all the [ __ ] now I saw hello what
it's all here not a good look on me good
actually it doesn't wait that much she's
pretty hot
that's from the Mesa it was a great
great game
I like that no I refuse to wear this I'm
wearing a yellow shirt Yolo right sorry
I'm taking it off sorry
so yeah oh I feel dirty we have this
huge huge package that looks amazing
oh good girl sorry girl who made this Oh
kids this box is full of awesome things
some art I need some are big that's what
she said some pay attention and look
closely that's what she said a lot of
sweet stuff is from Martina that's what
she said Jessica's mom Lowell that's
what she said ah it's me and my
girlfriend mine yeah that is adorable we
have baby Brune milk of course we have a
piggy I have about five of them I have
many of these but your ha ha it's like a
joke I made a [ __ ] two and a half
years ago
and I was literally like hey there's a
pig I should do something funny and bad
just elaborated up until this day where
I'm holding you with my thumb up your
butt
that is weird how YouTube works [ __ ] is
this
more Jandy uh-oh more jammy more candy
away for Philip I and Martha I hope you
like them
hey what's up you know is the jet when
they give you a kiss good thank you
oh I'm so flattered you breasts are just
so kinky yeah you know I asked for an
Oscar in my you stars swell haired and
[ __ ] it and it even says a genius
award it's like two two stones in one
penis I don't think that's how you say
it but [ __ ] it I have an Oscar look at
me now you [ __ ] barrels you ain't got
[ __ ] on this do you know how much [ __ ]
I get I didn't think so
I hope myself and I heard them walking
by do you see these moves do you see
these moves
do you know you do oh are you even
watching or did you tap out or some [ __ ]
because you're missing out on some
serious sweet ass bull all my hair today
it's doing all kinds of weird [ __ ] what
somebody games we got Batman the video
game why would you send me two of the
same game oh wait okay it's a sequel
inside I got this game is awesome and
this game is awesome too
I really I like that you bros send me
games keep sending me games if you want
don't don't you don't have money don't
you dare send me anything I've been able
to rely on you your videos to help me
get by and feel better about everything
so thank you I appreciate that you put
your YouTube content
I'm if it's like anything that really
like motivates me to put out videos it's
not really I make videos because it's
like it's fun in generally I mean that's
the thing but if there's really
something that motivates me to put extra
effort its its comments not saying that
you bros you watch me every day and it
makes you happier to watch it I guess I
don't know my nose is getting really
shiny
haha [ __ ] yeah I don't know I'm really
sure this is not a PewDiePie plushie
that is awesome
kind of creepy on my eyes are all black
but I love it it's so cool
thank you thank you saying thank you but
it's like oh I guess I can give myself
up a package inside a package [ __ ]
Jamie s though I'm pretty sure my
boyfriend is a bit jealous of you
because I watch your videos often myself
watches a lot of other boy youtubers he
doesn't she doesn't watch me as much as
she watches some other people so I can
relate brother can't relate like it's
super tiny
Slender Man play this awesome game it's
my favorite and it has Sailor Moon and a
[ __ ] bar to be riding a unicorn on it
I can't tell if you are trolling or not
but either way well played so I'm not
sure why you would send me a nail polish
but I love it no way oh my god this is
gonna be awesome
exploding brows man
ah so awesome oh yeah I got it I got it
ha ha ha there will be exploding brofist
and VidCon there pits and the first time
I saw one of your videos I actually
didn't like you it was some Anisha did a
while back you were a quick-paced loud
and had no strategy in the way you
played but I realized right after that
that was what made you so fun does is
don't you
it was and still is so entertaining to
see you just run into something and
freak the hell out after you made me
laugh in the worst times and lived up
when I'm severely bored thanks for the
fun laughs screams and tears it's a real
array I oh yeah hi caring is important
too oh yeah it's so detailed with the
legs and everything that's awesome haha
I love it thanks man it's an M magnet
it's also cool I hear there's a new
ending to it but I don't know if it's
worth repaying you tell me if you've
seen it and we have a pulip I brofist
I'll wear this every day and I'm on
official bro [ __ ] you're such
an amazing person you really are
no I'm not I know so many people watch
your videos when they are having a bad
day and it cheers them up like neurotic
your weird silly personality has helped
me through some dark times in my life
every single one of your videos brings a
smile to my face I hope you like your
bro badge I do I'm wearing it's a thorn
the me mom of my friends my grandma but
she just calls you hi the Italian guy
Jania
all right friends I hope you enjoyed
watching this episode I want to thank
you all for all the awesome mail and all
the super nice messages I can't tell you
how much that means to me
it really liked you bro say it brightens
your day when you watch my videos well
you bros support and awesomeness that's
that's what brightness money rolls out
of the base as always I it really it
really touches me inappropriately and
when I hear me do stuff like this my
hair and I are gonna have a little talk
but it's time to end this video thank
you for watching hope you enjoyed it
along if you did and subscribe to from
abroad today and I'll see in the next
episode sails and breath love you
come on activate
so yeah liberating what you think and
now I'll take more than this vertically
face I'll skip a second it's this